it's friday april third and you're
watching gamespot news I'm Chris waters
here to host our traditional end of the
week top five in which we run down the
hottest freshest and hottest stories of
the week we're gamespot news the source
you can trust blood-borne has barely
been out for over a week and already
some dedicated maniacs are posting
ludicrous speed runs this one guy beat
it in 44 minutes using some exploits
this other dude beat it as the week is
starting class without leveling up or
using guns what's next painting it
blindfolded no one would ever do that oh
yeah I guess no people totally do that
so yeah it's probably just a matter of
time wow I mean I pushed a guy off a
ledge last night and felt pretty good
about it so mortal kombat x is out very
soon and we now know all the characters
featured in the core roster during a
live stream earlier this week developer
nether realms revealed the entire roster
congratulations to all the characters
selected for this tremendous honor I
look forward to seeing more of your
inside parts and feeling slightly queasy
two very big games were recently delayed
until 2016 so get ready to wait another
year to play the witcher 3 and metal
gear solid 5 the phantom pain hybrid
wolf oh gotcha man saying not true stuff
is the best for real though it was The
Legend of Zelda Wii U that was delayed
last weekend as Nintendo said they've
discovered new possibilities in the open
world that they need time to fully
realize yadda yadda not showing at e3
blah blah blah also the microsoft
exclusive quantum break isn't going to
come out until next year normal the TV
show that will accompany a new expansion
for hearthstone launched this week that
will take players to Blackrock Mountain
where they'll discover and guessed it
more cards
the expansion is divided into five
weekly updates which you can purchase
separately or all at once and all told
it will deliver 31 new cards for your
dueling pleasure to see what each and
every one of those bad boys and girls
can do go to gamespot com / news and the
top story of the week is the landslide
of announcements that Nintendo
avalanched everybody with during a press
conference on Wednesday some highlights
include a newer faster scarier 200cc
mode for mario kart 8 a bunch of new
amoebas that sell out before they go on
sale and your chance to vote for the
next dlc character for super smash
brothers nintendo has said that they'll
only consider nintendo characters though
so tough nuts all you Garfield fans you
can catch up on all the other news tendo
on gamespot com of course and we
encourage you to not just because it
makes our job is possible but because it
is only to knowledge that we can truly
grow as people discover our true
potential and find our work in the
waking world but also because we need to
get paid so cliquey cliquey thanks for
watching see you later